qu'est ce que vous faites quand vous
avez un problème de santé un peu bizarre
et que vous vous dites que ça vaut pas
la peine de prendre rendez vous ou que
vous n'osez pas en parler à votre
médecin vous googlé où vous cherchez la
réponse sur les films de santé ok mais
si vous trouvez pas la réponse qu'est ce
que vous faites en général vous posez la
question genre à un pote qui travaille
dans le milieu de la santé par exemple
si je sais que vous faites ça ou alors
vous allez sur les forums de santé
carrément merci si je sais que vous
faites ça aussi parce que je suis allé
regarder depuis durée vous du coup je me
suis dit que ça pourrait être
intéressant de faire un petit tour de
toutes ces questions ensemble d'y
répondre et d'en faire une espèce de
série de l'été vous allez voir parfois
c'est surprenant d'ailleurs cette chaire
est pour l'instant elle n'a pas vraiment
de nom donc si vous avez une idée
n'hésitez pas à vous me dites ça dans
les commentaires allez c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dès que je suis debout j'ai l'impression
d'être saoul ou que je marche sur des
oeufs ou de tanguay j'ai été voir un
médecin après les examens des oreilles
scan de la tête on ne trouve rien et
pourtant ça va en empirant je ne sais
plus quoi faire je peux plus me
promenais car ça devient pénible car
j'ai peur de tomber si une personne a eu
ce genre de problème qu'il n'explique ce
qu'il a j'attends avec impatience merci
alors évidemment je vais pas répondre
aux problèmes de cette personne pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce qu'elle
est pas là cette personne à sofia le
regarde cette vidéo évidemment ensuite
parce que ça reviendrait à poser un
diagnostic médical que pour ça il faut
être médecin et que moi je suis
infirmier pas médecin et pour finir
parce que de toute façon même les
médecins il pose pas des diagnostics
comme ça à partir d'une question posée
sur un forum mais quand même ça vous est
peut-être déjà arrivé ce genre de truc
donc c'est pas mal d'en parler il ya
quelques pistes avoir la tête qui tourne
ou avoir cette sensation d'être bourré
comme ça tout le temps ça peut avoir
plusieurs causes déjà en gros ça peut
être classée dans 2 catégories les
vertiges ou les malaises les vertiges ça
peut être le signe qu'il ya un problème
au niveau des centres de l' équilibre
qui se trouve au niveau de l'oreille
interne c'est sûrement pour ça que la
personne parle d' examens au niveau de
l'oreille on en avait déjà un petit peu
parlé dans la vidéo sur les manèges à
sensations fortes je vous invite
chaleureusement à retourner juste un
petit coup d'oeil si ça vous intéresse
quand il ya une atteinte au niveau de
ces fameux centre de l'equilibre genre
les nerfs ou les structures ça fait
bugger le système et ça peut donner
cette impression qu'on a la tête qui
tourne ou que tout tourne autour de nous
surtout quand on fait des mouvements de
la tête un peu brusque ou quand on se
lève il ya d'autres causes possibles au
vertige comme des atteintes cérébrales
ou au niveau du système nerveux sûrement
pour ça qu'on lui a fait passer un
scanner mais avant de penser à tout ça
on peut envisager d'autres scénarios un
petit peu moins pas dans ce genre c'est
juste des petits malaises par exemple là
encore il ya plein de causes possibles
et si vous cherchez sur google je suis
sûr que vous allez vous imaginez que
vous avez le pire truc possible
évidemment mais il ya un truc qui vous
est peut-être déjà arrivé là même pas
mal de chance vous êtes allongé ou même
vous êtes juste assis vous vous lever
d'un coup et là vous avez la tête qui
tourne vous sentez pas bien vous
commencez à voir des étoiles et c est
bien ça s'appelle de l'hypotension
orthostatique
alors oui le nom est un petit peu
flippant mais en fait ça va en fait ce
pas c'est que quand vous vous levez d'un
coup comme ça il ya beaucoup de sang qui
descend dans vos jambes votre corps il
est fait adapté mais vous faites une
chute de tension et quand la tension
baisse comme ça surtout quand elles
baissent rapidement bas ça donne ce
genre de malaise qui peut aller jusqu'à
la perte de connaissance dans l'absolu
c'est pas méchant mais si vous savez que
vous avez tendance à faire ça c'est bien
de prendre son temps quand vous vous
levez et d'attendre un petit peu avant
de commencer à vous déplacer histoire de
ne pas tomber si vous perdez
connaissance et de pas vous faire mal et
puis si ça vous arrive souvent en bas
c'est quand même pas mal définis de
comprendre ce qui se passe alors en en
parlant à votre médecin par cherchant
sur google mais avant de penser à tout
ça on peut encore penser à un autre type
de scénario si vous avez fait sensation
et briouze en permanence c'est à dire
cette sensation d'être bourrée tout le
temps c'est peut-être parce que vous
êtes bourrés tout le temps donc que vous
consommez très régulièrement de l'alcool
et donc que vous avez un problème avec
l'alcool on en a déjà parlé plusieurs
fois dans différentes vidéos je vous
remets les liens dans la description et
je vous invite à aller checker ça allait
question suivante bonjour aujourd'hui
j'ai remarqué avoir une tâche rouge dans
l'oeil je les montrer à mon ami il jure
voir le visage d'un homme avec de longs
cheveux il a pris une photo j'ai poussé
un cri tellement je vois ce visage qu'en
pensez vous ok là on est dans un autre
domaine on est à deux doigts de jésus
apparaît dans le blanc des yeux mais en
vrai pourquoi on a parfois des veines
qui pètent dans les yeux déjà il faut
savoir que ce qu'on voit sur la photo ça
s'appelle un nip ostheim
encore un mot flippant alors que en bref
avant on dit aussi une hémorragie sous
conjonctivale mais à vrai dire c'est pas
beaucoup plus rassurant en fait ça veut
juste dire qu'il ya un peu de sang enfin
plus ou moins bref ça veut dire qu'il ya
du sang qui fait déposer entre la
conjonctive c'est à dire la membrane
transparente qui recouvre l'oeil et l'as
clair c'est à dire le blanc de l'oeil
c'est un petit vaisseau qui claquent et
du sang qui reste là en attendant d'être
résorbée c'est un bleu en fait mais dans
l'oeil et en rouge ça perturbe pas la
vision a priori ça fait pas mal mais
évidemment ça dépend de la raison pour
laquelle le vaisseau a pété parfois on
sait pas trop pourquoi ça arrive c'est
même assez fréquents parfois c'est parce
que la tension est montée un peu fort
d'un coup genre pendant un effort et
parfois c'est à cause d'un traumatisme
direct au niveau de l'oeil et là ok ça
peut faire mal mais c'est de trauma qui
fait mal pas le fait qu'ils aient du
sens donc dans l'absolu c'est pas
méchant mais là encore comme d'habitude
il faut aller vérifier qui a pas un
problème derrière genre des problèmes de
tension de coagulation du sang ou juste
checker que le choc n'a pas abîmé l'oeil
et évidemment on peut aussi checker à
qui appartient ce visage parce que c'est
pas forcément jésus
allez on passe à la suite bonjour
bonsoir voila en ce moment j'ai quelques
petites péter fille qui apparaissent
mais comme elles partent assez vite je
me suis inquiété mais pas tant que ça
sauf que là je viens de voir que j'en ai
sur le palais et j'ai peur d'une
leucémie ou quoi est ce que quelqu'un a
déjà eu ça merci d'avancé pour vos
réponses et bonne journée bonne soirée à
toutes tes pesci dans la bouche alors
c'est pas une pratique scato c'est
encore une histoire de vaisseaux
sanguins pour situer un petit peu le
truc l'épée tai chi c'est des petites
taches rouges qui apparaissent sur la
peau elles sont pas en relief et elles
disparaissent pas quand on appuie dessus
c'est des micro hémorragies sous la peau
et là encore elles peuvent avoir plein
de causes très différentes un peu comme
pour les vaisseaux qui pètent dans
l'oeil ça peut être causée pas un effort
violent ou un trouble de la coagulation
ça peut aussi être un effets secondaires
d'un médicament ou une infection virale
par exemple et donc oui ça peut aussi
être à cause d'une leucémie mais avant
de penser à ça comme la personne qui a
laissé ce message qu'il ya plein
d'autres causes à considérer attention
je ne juge pas un c'est complètement
humain d'avoir peur et de s'imaginer le
pire mais c'est quand même mieux de
chercher à être fixés de manière
rationnelle genre en allant chez le
médecin pour vérifier d'où ça vient
c'est à dire pourquoi j'ai des petits
vaisseaux qui ont pété dans la bouche ou
ailleurs parce qu'on peut avoir des p&t
chi partout sur le corps voilà donc des
pesci ça arrive parfois c'est rien c'est
juste que vous avez un peu trop forcé à
la salle où que vous avez vous mis de
manière violente
coup story dans ces cas-là ça disparaît
comme c'est venu c'est à dire en
quelques jours et on en parle plus mais
si ça persiste ou que ça recommence et
encore plus si vous avez de la fièvre en
même temps passé en parler à votre
médecin allez next elle au petit topic
original suite à une discussion que j'ai
eue avec un autre naturistes qui ne
partageaient pas la même vision que moi
selon lui il est inconcevable qu'un
naturiste comme moi puisse être
passionné par l'automobile et donc par
les voitures thermiques
lui un naturiste doit être pris par une
conscience écologique forte et donc doit
circuler en voiture 100% électrique ou
pire en vélo après un long débat que je
ne souhaite plus renouveler je viens
donc ouvrir ce topic assez originale
avec cette question vous roulez dans
quelle voiture ah
ah oui un peu de tout sur les forums
santé je vous avais prévenu alors je m'y
connais pas trop en bagnole j'avoue
après pour ce qui est des conséquences
de nos actes sur le dérèglement
climatique qu'on préfère le textile ou
qu'on aime vivre cul nu si on aime vivre
tout court on a intérêt à faire les bons
choix vite d'ailleurs si possible parce
qu'on n'a plus le temps d'ailleurs je
vous renvoie à ma vidéo sur les
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
sur notre santé je vous remets le lien
dans la description vous connaissez j'en
profite quand même pour glisser un ou
deux petits conseils santé aux
naturistes surtout aux naturistes
débutants parce que les autres savent ça
par coeur gardez bien à l'esprit que
vous vous exposez quelque chose qui
d'habitude est bien à l'abri vos
muqueuses génitales et n'oubliez pas que
les muqueuses c'est comme la peau mais
en beaucoup plus fragile donc pour ne
pas gâcher cette belle expérience de
liberté qu'est le naturisme penser deux
fois plus fort à tous les petits
réflexes de prévention habituel tout ce
qui concerne le soleil les piqûres
d'insectes les brûlures de l'arbre ku et
c et l'hygiène tant qu'on y est en bonus
vous rend voir la vidéo sur les pires
conseils santé parce qu'ils parlent pas
mal de muqueuses génitales bizarrement
on va en rester là pour aujourd'hui mais
je vais revenir donc avec ce format
parce que les forums santé c'est une
mine de questions qu'on ne se pose pas
forcément et pourtant d'ailleurs si vous
fréquentez ce genre de site dans les
forums santé et que vous voyez des
questions particulièrement what the fuck
ou particulièrement intéressante
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un message
vous avez tous mes réseaux sociaux dans
la description et puis n'hésitez pas non
plus à m'aider à trouver un nom pour ce
nouveau format voilà donc des tfc fini
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très
vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des
autres mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]